while we are in class we covered a lot
of different types of models generative
models sised models today we're going to
specifically dive deep into language
models before we do that um we've been
reading through your project proposals
personally I'm through all but four of
them I apologize if you're one of the
four um I hope to get through the last
four by tonight um put some comments in
your Google doc if I put some comments
with a question please put answer in so
I understand how you're thinking about
it if there's no question then you know
keep going and just incorporate the the
comments as you think about things um
keep in mind there's a milestone due in
April and then the final project uh
report and video presentation is due in
May um your homework three is was due
yesterday and your homework four is
already released um which is diffusion
models that's the last homework so you
have one homework left and then final
project so today we have a guest lecture
howu howu is a final year phg student
here at Berkeley he's done some of the
most impressive work on training uh
large models across reinforcement
learning language modeling multimodal
learning um video modeling the whole
Spectrum uh but today is going to focus
on language models how take it away yeah
thank you uh so yeah so today's lecture
is about language model and Peter asked
me to talk about the basics and some uh
advances in language model so uh Here We
Begin so in today's uh lecture um I'm
going to cover some of the scill NOS
Basics and some capabilities of language
model and in the second half I will talk
about some practical guidelines for for
your research or maybe there some
practical
purpose so language model is
everywhere from chat
boo code
co-pilot or even image generation or
video generation like Google's imagine
or op's recent releas Sora or these
incredible successes are based on
language model and understanding
language really well means a lot for
various AI
applications so one of the secret
sources is our techniques for building
language model really leverage enormous
computer
power and in today's lecture I'm going
to focus on how these techniques scale
always compute and what are the
remaining Bots and how many how we may
address them in the
future so a language model is basically
a probability distribution over
sequences we model the likelihood
distribution which is parameterized by
some
Theta and our goal is to model such
sequences of tokens okay imagine you
have sequence of wordss or maybe a
sequence of other tokens like virtual
tokens or so on and you want to learn
some parameters such that you can
capture the distribution of such
sequences so typically language models
are autor regressive we're going to
factorize this sequence Auto
regressively basically the T tokens
going to condition on only tokens before
all that
token and typically we parameterize the
model using Transformer which we will
get to
later to really simple objective Auto
regressive likelihood distribution over
sequence of
tokens so why we want to do
autoagressive fractalization we have so
many different ways of model language
sequences I would say the primary reason
is every bit becomes part of the
separation because we are again we are
doing Auto regressive prediction so we
have to predict every token so if you
have five words then all the five words
become the prediction Targets this turns
out to be crucial for scaling of the
language
model another reason is since we are
doing autog prediction is really lateral
for conversational
AI I think the primary reason that we
say the success of CH GPT is that we can
interact with such AI model and such AI
model can predict
language so
realistically so basically the objective
is requesting the model to predict the
future run
well so what is the maximum likelihood
doing the goal is to make observed data
likely under the
model we're going to take many sequences
compute the log
likelihood and we get average value and
that's our objective function we're
going to try to maximize this
objective so in the Lama language model
you probably heard about we have 1.5
trillion of
tokens and the seta is often times
billions of
parameters so during learning we
actually have three
stages the first stage is called large
scale pre-training
where we maximize the likelihood of over
a large very large data set of
sequences once we have the model we can
fune this model to some specific tasks
because remember during
pre-training we model the data
distribution like and the data is like a
trillions of tokens come from the
internet they may not capture the task
we really care
about for certain tasks so often times
you want to do some little bit of fan
tuning you're in Pre training
model and the third stage is called
learning from
feedback when you have a good model you
want this model to follow user's
intention and user may give some
feedback and this stage focus on how to
use this humans feedback to align the
model in today's lecture I'm going to
mainly focus on
pre-training because that's where you
can build your that basically determines
like how good your model
is and I will spend some time I'm fan
tuning and learning from
feedback so so far you may have the
question like why we are doing this Auto
regressive unised
learning
this figure is from the Llama paper
showing the
pre-training
stage the Y
AIS the previously
mentioned the average L likelihood loss
lower is
better and the xaxis is the number of
tokens seen during this training
stage as you can see we have three ions
of tokens during training and they
probably notice that these curves they
are not
saturated that continuously decreasing
and we have way more data on the
internet for
language so that's one of the major
reason why we do unsupervised learning
because there are so many unlabeled data
available and by training these
trillions or hundreds of trillions
tokens
the model captures the
distribution very
well and can generalize much better than
doing supervised
learning so you probably heard son
called beter lesson from the famous
reach
s which is saying that
the major AI
successes going to come
from methods that leverage
computation so our goal is to model the
data distribution better by adding more
comput so what is
compute compute
is the forward and backward
path we have a bunch of tokens we run
our
model comput the loss the back
propagation that's how we spend
compute and this compute are mostly
matrix
multiplication and we measure this
compute using
flops because this matrix
multiplication are basically doing
floating
Point multiplication and
addiction we can actually estimate the
compute cost I will get to this a bit
later but the formulation here is just
to show you that the computer cost
C is determined by the your number of
parameters basically the model size your
data
size and your context Dimension and
model hidden
Dimension I will explain this a bit
later this is to show that we can add
more
compute by increasing the number of
tokens by using more parameters
by using Niger context
window so collecting more data longer
the sequence of data or training bigger
models why we are doing this like are
there evidence showing that if we do
this we indeed get much better AI
models now I'm going to talk about token
which is the basic and then we move to
answer the question I previous
asked so I mentioned in the tokens
multiple
times we can model bite
sequence it's most
General but often times it's very l
right so for a single digit we spend you
know one
bite so if we going to model a sequence
of language words you're going to easily
have extremely long
sequences I will show later that longer
sequences means a lot of more compute
and it's a little bit unnecessary you
know training is very
expensive
the another alternative is to do
character
based so if I have a word like
hello I will represent this word using
the characters in this
world so you can imagine each world
going to have at least few
tokens and the longer word can have more
tokens so it has a similar problem to
bite based
sequence people tried world based
tokenization the problem is the model
does know that some words they have very
similar semantical
meaning so nowadays we typically do a
trade-off in between we some we use
something called bite pair encoding
which I been was briefly covered in
previous
lectures but for those who are not
familiar with
this it works by replacing top appearing
pair with a new
token so have bunch of wordss bunch of
sequences you split this word into
subw and then you repeatingly look at
okay so maybe these two subword
occur most
frequently then you find a new token you
basically assign a new token you know
any token to replace these two appearing
um pair and you keep repeating this
until you reach a certain given
vocabulary
size
so people try to train LM with more
compute a few years ago
2017 they basically take
arcm and do what we previous talked
about Auto regress n token
production and very large amount of
Amazon
reviews after doing this something
interesting
happened they found that there's a new
room in the
STM whose
value is sh on the X
AIS can be
controlled can be used to control the
output output of a te
and the Y AIS shows the
number s outputs that are either
positive or
negative so you can see that by
controlling this neurons value we can
basically generate either positive or
negative
RS so basically model learns to
understand
to
distinguish positive and negative
basically to understand human
sentiment this was considered as a
really difficult task back
then and if we
take IMDb
reviews and check the value of this
neuron Auto regressively over this um
paragraph We can again shows that the
neurons captures human sentiment like
the red one
indicate negative words or sentences and
so more green one indicate more positive
sentiment so
that's was really interesting back then
I think many people like me tried
to collect more data to play with this
or train a little bit of bigger l or
other alternative neuronet
architectures maybe you can discover
something Beyond human sentiment maybe
you can
understand more borly about human
language because Amazon reviews also
contain not just sentiment also World
Knowledge but this far very
difficult it really difficult to train
stn
and people wrote a paper about
this people propos a new architecture
called
attention attention scales much better
the left figure
here
shows per
token test loss okay per token loss
means if I look at particular position
over this 1K 1,000
tokens which model can predict this
token better so xaxis is a token
index and Y AIS is this the losss
correspond to that particular
token we can see that the the red lines
are
LM and the blue lines are for
Transformer across different model size
as we train bigger and bigger neuron
networks Transformers
consistently hold performance
STM and you can see that as the context
gets longer gets to 1K Tokens The Gap
becomes much
larger and this led to the right figure
is the model average
performance the XX becomes the
parameters because we care about how can
we build more capable models by scaling
app
so here we see that Transformers shows a
very
beautiful linear scaling well
asms saturate very
early so I want to briefly recap the
Transformer
architecture as we previously show
attention allows attending to pass
tokens without Fus
LM you have to maintain certain hidden
state but in
attention you can directly attend to any
pass
tokens the model does not have this
information botom
it and another reason Transformer spills
so
well
is that you can increase your parameters
easily by adding bigger MLP
networks and MLP networks is just matrix
multiplication right really big matrix
multiplication so it scales really well
with our generations of gpus and
tpus
something I want to talk about again
about the objective
is typically we do auto regress
prediction but you probably heard about
other
objectives like masked token
prediction or
prefix token
prediction of good example of this
masked
or masked language modeling is
bir birth works by taking a sentence
randomly mask out let's say 50% of the
words and train the model to predict
these mask dat
parts and GPT is more like the four
language modeling you condition on
previous tokens and predict the next or
future
tokens something in the middle is called
a prefix language modeling it's good to
know that it's not widely used
but it works by let's say the first
three words here Major
Force have bidirectional attention mask
so the word may can attend to force and
the force the world force can also
attend back to M but after
that it's Auto regressive prediction
okay so the word you can only can attend
to all the previous tokens but the word
way can attend to
you I want to say
that there are some PR and counts of
these
alternatives mask language modeling is
really great for certain purposes let's
say you want to learn a embedding
model it turns
out well actually intuitively if you
want to learn a embedding like by
embedding I mean like a hidden Vector
that
represents a sentence okay in this case
you probably don't want to do auto
regress prediction because the four
sematic meaning of this given sentence
is best model by having the attention
mask you know attending to the sentence
by directionally right attending to the
four sequence okay so if you want to
build a embedding model for you know
like a retrieval for
search then yeah you probably want to
train a mask language modeling because
you know it captures the full sentence
capture the sematic meaning better and
it turns out it's a easier task so you
can train you know a small bird mode
right the largest birth model back then
was less than 1 billion parameters but
nowadays for this Auto request full
language
modeling in the one billion model is
often times too way too small uh to be
useful and the prefix language model is
interesting internationally
because many of the encoder decoder
models they can be reformulated as you
know like Auto regressive prediction but
with a different attention mask like a
prefix attention mask right you can
think of as the the B directional part
is the encoder it's by directional you
know any words can attend to each other
in this window and then after that in
the auto regressive part it's the
decoder
okay so better virtualization is
this the x axis and y axis are both you
know the tokens and their a sequence of
token and the prefix language model is
shoting in the
middle
and the most widely used L GPT
model is the first
diagram so computationally wise we pay
the same almost the same amount flops
for these different objectives
but the C encode COA decoder turns out
to be most
scalable so I guess many of you have
probably thought about different
alternative architectures for
Transformers and want to point out
that there was the paper showing that
you know for this
arber or many other really really
interesting ideas you know alternative
architectures if
we plot the you know the pre-training
log perplexity against the flops we
spend during
training the green L represents the the
vanilla
Transformer and the red lines represent
many other uh I say really interesting
ideas um alternative models and most
of
um you know they they do not scale that
well
um and this is a downstream uh
performance if we look at the B stream
performance um most of the other
architecture es uh seem to be
underperformed by Transformer so during
your research um I would highly
recommend to uh check like this the plot
the how how you you know um future new
ideas uh scale against um flops and are
they um do they have better scaling law
than the vanina Transformers
I think it's it's good to to check that
um and many of the U models showing here
are actually quite useful for certain
cases so uh if you are interested I
would encourage you to check them out
that pretty cool
work so I want to go to the compute cost
and
uh give you a sense of how we estimate
compute cost which is really useful for
later
slides yeah stand are you dividing by
small b or you multiply
small oh yeah so yeah so this is divided
by small
D yeah yeah so yeah so here I sorry
about that this is s s stands for the
sequence lens and it's divided by six
times small D and D is the hidden size
so this is not saying that if we
increase hidden size we canot get a a
lower computer cost that's not true
because the total parameters n the
capital N uh you know you have many
Matrix right uh so the total parameters
scales quadratically with the small D so
um it actually skills linearly um
with your number of parameters so larger
models has uh more computer
cost this is the hidden size of the MLP
this is the hidden size of the um the
input of the MLP or the uh the
projection Dimension the hidden size of
MLP is usually four times of the small d
right have this expanding factor in MLP
Network
yeah
so I encourage you to evaluate this
formula by hand you know you
can and comput the flops the number of
the parameters it's good
to to do such simple uh
exercise
um
okay so for Lama language
model where s is UN like 4,000 or
2000 and the dimension D is
usually about
4,000 or even 8,000 so s is much smaller
than six times small
D to
typical
we can think of the compute cost spills
linearly with the product of number
parameters and the number of
tokens so we if we plug in seven billion
parameters and two trillion
tokens we can see the flops is is a
pretty insane it's 10 to the power of
22 so this Bears the question we're
going to spend this huge amount of
compute and training the language model
and we know that it scills linearly with
the product of number parameters model
size
then how do I allocate my model
size shall I allocate my computer to the
model size or the number of
tokens
people tried to discover whether there's
a I would say scaling
l or maybe scaling
hypothesis the people train models with
different size different number of
tokens these are the light blue lens so
people train you know like a SP
different compute that which is the xais
and then they check the the test loss on
some unseen uh data
set and then then vary the model size
and the number token so you so they get
different um you know like the blue lens
and then for each blue lens you know
each blue lens represent one
configuration right so we can pick the
lowest point you know the lowest point
for this configur configurations like
the optimal loss we can achieve for this
particular configuration you know this
particular um model size or number of
tokens and then we can draw the black
Lane you know that's basically the
minimum l
l and it turns out this is a log log uh
correlation you know it's more like a
power
LW you can get the coefficient by you
know doing the regression you can f this
black line you know the test loss
against compute
right so this is telling us
that this seems to be
a power low relationship
between each individual factor and the
performance you know if I'm not
constrained by my data size
then the best way for me to allocate my
number of parameters is to you know plug
in the L you know like if we look at
this the middle uh plot right uh it's
the test L equals something you know um
the variable is D number of tokens so if
I'm not constrained by my model size
then I can just keep increasing the data
size and then I get this linearly
decreasing
l
so we know how the optimal number of
tokens and parameters scale if we are
not constrained by another Factor but
actually we constrained by other Factor
right
because we want to we have a fixed
amount of comput say and now we know the
optimal scaling for each individual
factor and you know tokens and the data
side you know the model size and data
side and since we know the compute say
equals something you know 6 * n d we
plug this together then we know that the
power low coefficient a and b equals one
right so now we know they equals one
then simpler simpler than before now but
how do we allocate
compute
there are a bunch of papers studing in
this you know before gpt3 came out OPI
wrote this paper um actually this this
paper scaling know for neur language
model um it's showing as the first row
in this
table so op found
that you want to probably allocate more
of your
compute to your number of parameters so
you think you should train bigger models
rather than train more data and later on
the second row is another paper I will
get to more details later it run a bunch
of different experiments using different
data
States and they found okay probably they
are roughly equal you know maybe the
data set data number um any data is more
important because it's Point 51
right I would say the best
practice is to train different small
models and data size
and you can fit the constant by yourself
right you can do something like this
train a bunch of small models you don't
need to train really big B models ENT TR
really small models with different
number of tokens you get a bunch of this
blue Lanes pick their lowest point draw
the black lane and then you can fit this
constant that's what I would recommend
for your research or you know um other
purpose that's mostly
reliable can't you just look it up in
the paper somebody else what's different
about
yourself good question so this table
here shows that these
constants are highly dependent on the
data
side and since these data sets are
not properly available right we don't
know what data set open our de used um
you know like for my past research I use
the data sets are probably different
from other research papers people
published so the best way to do this is
to fit the constant by yourself and then
you can convince the readers that uh you
know your research idea indeed skills
really
well so the chinchila paper came out
later that they show that okay uh you
know um it turns out maybe we should
allocate more computer to data and
should train more data rather than you
know just increasing our motor size this
is Wily adopted today so it's a it's a
pretty good um estimation that I also
check this is fits um you know most data
sets very
well
so this plot shows
that if you follow this Skilling law
this chinchila Skilling
law many of the published models before
chincha they say gp3
Megatron
goer this spend way more parameters
right so the approach one approach two
approach three these three names are
slightly different estimation according
to chincha SK know because because you
know when you train model you have a
little bit different let say hyper
parameters and so on so in the end your
estimation has a little bit of variance
so but all these three lines show
that most of the existing models back
then wasted their
compute and increasing the motor size
because these three star they are all
way way higher
than you know the three lines sh
there so that's not
ideal what's the dash line oh the dash
line is um the original OPI
scale so basically the first row
here so they put more weights on the
motor side you can say s three
yeah so turns out after the going know
most of the models after that follow did
this scale you know they increase the
model number of parameters we get dg3
100 billion over 100 billion and then
graer is almost 300 billions and the
Megatron is like 500 billions
parameters
yeah so it's more like an empirical
observation right uh so people unit say
is like Skilling law but I would say
it's more like a scaling hypothesis uh
we found you if you train different
model look at the minimum loss with you
know like the minimum loss you can
achieve for certain Compu right that's
the first
figure oh say that
again any insights on what on why is
parel yeah great question
um yeah I I don't have a good intuition
on like why is parel holds in
practice um I would
say firstly it's not going to be
exponential right because that's it's
going to be very crazy spend a little
bit more computer exponentially more
capable a model so it's it's not
exponential then it's probably the
inverse of exponential right it's
per yeah I I would encourage more
research on this like understand why
it's often times parel as seems parallel
holds uh widely in physics mathematics
and many other sense sense domains so
um yeah does that answer your question
Okay cool so we covered it the basics of
scill in law and I hope that's useful
for
for your work or research
um and turns out if you allocate your
compute
wisely okay so this figure shows
that by spending the same amount of
compute you have you have two models
okay chinchila and
grafer if you follow the chinchila
Skilling mode
they have a way better
model the x-axis is a bunch of different
language modeling
tasks okay people care about these tasks
and the y axis is how much is CH L
better than the grafer model on that
task and we can see that for most of the
task because I'll say like between 10%
to 30% better performance this spend the
same amount compute you get much better
model
yeah is always going to be or is it just
this one obervation but in models
different yeah I guess if you compare
chin with other previously available
models I think you will get a different
you know uh this plots
yeah it's not like a very specific I
would say I would say like the yeah you
can see like the college mathematics is
a little bit worse right um
but most of the other tasks like other
tasks also look at reasoning like a high
school geometric High School mathematics
yeah yeah so I would say there are
some I
maybe if you want get like model that
consistently better than all the tasks
then
yeah I think it depends on many factors
not just the scill you know right skill
not tells you how to spend compute using
your data set but if the data set is
maybe worse than other data sets you
know maybe another model you train out
better data sets higher quantity data
this this scaling not does not guarantee
you a better model
right
yeah yeah and it's going more mostly
about how do you spend your Compu yeah
yeah do
know draw a line is like extrapolation
how do you know
that
how do
know
after then maybe at that point
dat yeah that's a really good question
so I would
say some people use the word scale in
law I see is more like a hypothesis you
know uh you look at these lines and they
are not flat they are not saturating you
know this seems to hold across you the
xaxis is the log scale so it seems like
this U power low holds across different
scales so people hypothesize that okay
hypothesize that this will be true for
lat say 10 times or 100 times larger
scale
um
but I can't be sure that let's say if we
scale the compute
by you know one million times whether
this GNA hurt be true it it's it's hard
to say
yeah
great
um so now suppose you want to do maybe
some research some work related to
language
model and you realize you don't want to
train a bunch of small models to fix the
constants right like it's it's a lot of
work there are simple rule of samp I can
follow yes so the change
paper shows this
table and let's look at the second
column and the fourth column the second
column tells you if you have this amount
of flops to
spend and the First Column three tells
the the model set you know if you have
400 million parameters and this amount
of flops then you probably want to spend
eight billion tokens
okay this is a bunch of
suggestions and then we can easily say
that the number of tokens is roughly 20
times the number of parameters
right so that's a good rule samp but I
would say it's best to double this
estimate in
practice so if you're going to train one
billion
model you probably want to TR 40 billion
tokens you know rather than 20 times
it's 40 times why it's just a suggestion
I feel like you know if somebody show
this in their research papers or you
know work then yeah I think me and many
other most people going to be convinced
that yeah this is a this is really
convincing this is a good choice
yeah great um so does this tell does
this mean that we have to you know uh
choose let's say 40 times number of
token you know we're going to CH one
billion model then we're going to use 40
billion tokens Can I use
more uh of course
so um nowadays people do something
called inference optimal you have a lot
of compute let's say then you want to go
Way Beyond the CH optimal right so for
seven billion model uh at previous
mention we want to probably do 20 to 40
times of the number of parameters so
that's about um you know probably 400
billions of tokens and we can see that
this lama lama language model they
trained you know one trillion
tokens and the motivation is that I only
need to train this model once right and
then I can have a really good model for
inference so if I have have the computer
valuable why not spend the computer and
training the model really really long
right because at the inference time you
only pay the cost for the seven billion
model right or whatever model size you
choose you only need to pay the computer
cost for that
model when you increase the parameters
where do you increase
them oh you make the model's hidden size
larger number of layers yeah yeah um it
depends yes you know you can increase
the hidden size or you can increase
number layer or increase both uh
typically you increase bow
yeah
mod like is there a scaling L for the
model size
yeah
scale like an increase in the model
size yeah um
you probably want to keep the ratio
between the let's say number of layers
and your hidden Dimension
fixed as you increase the model
parameter that's
a good
practice since uh early days in
convolution on your network
yeah but you don't want to increase
number later is too much because at the
inference
[Music]
time well if you increase the number of
layers too much it's sequential right
you kind of parallel you kind of
paralyze the number of
layers so it's slows down your inflence
but you also don't want to keep your
number of layers fixed and keep
increasing your hidden Dimension right
because your networks need certain
depths to be a good approximator
right okay
so this is an interesting observation I
would say is that the loss turns out to
be the determin factor for
performance so now let's say we trained
s bilon
model and we also trained this 765 bil
model what if I want to train a bigger
model on fewer number of
tokens okay because it's more expensive
right so maybe I can I only want to tr
my on much fewer number
tokens would I get the same quality
model or I'm going to get a worse
model that's found that if we draw a
line here okay this red
lines you know this basically the
same training loss right you can think
of this as test loss because the the
over the training period there's no
repeating data okay so all the data
trained
here it's more like one training so the
training loss is almost test loss right
because
the loss basically shows how the model
perform on new unseen data so you can
think of this as test
losss and if we look at the different
model size and pick the point where they
get the
same train SL test
loss we can say
that for the largest model that's
correspond 200 billion tokens for the
smallest model that correspond to 1
trillion tokens
okay now let's move on to the right the
the figures um the smaller
figures and we check the 200 billion
tokens and Al the 100 one trillion
tokens look at this Red Cross
dot we can see that we get the exact
same Downstream performance right the
trivia QA one with a popular Benchmark
and the H SW is another wly used pretty
difficult
task I didn't check this for other task
but I can roughly tell that this holds
true across different down
houses so this is R lies so in
practice when you have a new idea or
you're going to train a model for your
company and so on
you know that if the data set is the
same then the loss you get if you get a
lower loss with whatever models whatever
model
size you get a better performance and if
you get a same loss you know okay these
two models perform roughly the
same so this figure May answer one of
the previous questions on how scaling no
hold a much larger scale Yeah question I
was wondering like train the tokens are
sample like randomly or like are weing
data based on like
quity since we have just one EO are we
using like low quality data first and
then like I don't know imagine a better
data yeah is there some kind of
scattering or just like randomly
sampling the
whole yeah so we R we do random sample
uh we don't have like lower quality data
and know we put them first uh you don't
want to put lower quality data in the
pre-training um because I
would
dat too small yeah you have way more
data valuable on the internet right the
difficult part is how you fear
this
data right on the internet there are
almost um infinite amount month of
tokens right but some of data are
probably not that good so a good
heuristic is Wikipedia is really good
data because you know you might spent a
lot of efforts on curating them so but
let's say I don't know maybe some random
websites not not good data right not
much knowledge
um so you need you train a classifier to
check against whether this data is
similar to Wikipedia you do a
classification basically calibrate
towards Wikipedia and if you do this you
have way more data available that then
you can you could possibly train so um
so typically we don't mix um no coord
data into the training um and um for a
second part of question like do we do
any like a curriculum samping um to the
bestas of myy um seems like people don't
do that um you know like our objective
is the maximum likelihood right and
uh it's probably best if you sample your
training data from your distribution
right uniformally right rather
that from let the first step from
Wikipedia after training on Wikipedia we
move on to maybe Coral or whatever right
it's probably not a good idea
um uh yeah does that answer
good great so this slide is about you
know u l pretty much determine the
performance
um
so this slide is showing that turns out
in
practice SC can
predict long way ahead right if you look
at the x-axis is the log scale L flops
it's going to hold true
across really long
range so
um I want to talk about one one thing
um which is about the sequen
M it was a major botom like in language
model or in general like multi model
model as
so so we I want to model the
word not just the text so in the world
we have many
videos or if you want to try AI agent
using trial and error
experience I have long
trajectories if you want to understand
codebase or hyperlinked websites or
general
sequences all these require hundreds of
millions or even billions of tokens per
sequence and we can't fit
this into
Transformer because Transformer
attention has a high memory
cost so blockwise parallel Transformer
is the idea that breaks
down LM more computation graph of
Transformer so
tension
normally works by
modeling the pairwise interaction right
you have end tokens you comput the N to
n
byn attention weights right and then you
multiply this attention weights with
your value Matrix
right so this attention weight
Matrix has a quadratic memory
cost and that's not good you know if you
want to do millions of tokens per
sequence quadratic
means you know we can't even fix this
sequence into GPU or TPU or future
generation of
TPU
yeah
sorry yeah H that's good point yeah we
can chunk the sequence and then each GPU
each device holds one chunk right that
was thinking yeah that's a good
idea one problem with
that is attention is n to n right any to
any modeling
so gpu1 only has one
chunk but GP this one chunk also need to
attend to any other
chunk but the other chunks are not
available on this device so you need to
gather them you need to communicate them
back to the device so in the end your
device is still going to hold the four
sequence but we can't hold the four
sequence on one
device so the idea is that
we can reorganize the computation
ordering so imagine you're going to
compute the N byn Matrix you can take a
slice and maybe take a row slice that
you know the y axis is query x-axis key
value right query attemp to key value
that's your attention Matrix you take a
slides around the
query and now you have a much smaller
Matrix in order to compute
this you can either it over chance along
the key value
sequences that's called memory efficient
attenion and the blockwise Transformer
show that since we're going to break
down the
computation you know we have two Loops
one over the query each Loop each
iteration is responsible for one slice
and in the Inner Loop we iterate over
the key value
sequence so as we finish one of the
inner loop we have the output for that
particular slide quy slice then we can
go ahead to do the MLP computation we
don't need to wait until the attention
finish computation on the entire input
sequence we can we can move on to MLP
computation for that particular slice
and doing
so get a much lower memory
cost I want to sa a little bit time here
so I can probably go back get back here
later
on this is basically analyze of the
memory
cost
and can get it back
later this slide shows that if we
evaluate this in practice indeed we
get much lower memory cost and in return
we can train really long
sequences and this is true for different
models this the Google's recent
GMA
model we get if you apply this technique
you get 16 times lower memory cost
basically six times longer
sequen but this is not enough to
Dominion sequence
sequences because the memory cost still
scills linear new with Z
sequence and then we can't build the
chip ARR any large due to physics
constraints and using multiple GPU at
one of the previous question mentioned
you know basically Chunk in the sequence
along uh to multiple gpus couldn't help
because
attentions require pairwise
interaction it turns out we can
distribute the query Loop across
different
devices and then we communicate the Q
value between
devices how is this different from L
evenly chunk the sequence and distribute
them across PE well the key difference
is
that now the mental communication is
much smaller
order
because as we iterate over the key value
sequence we only need the next one from
the next device we don't need all all
other sequences from all other devices
as we do our current key value we can
receive the next key value from next
device and then at the same time we can
send our copy to the previous device
like this is like in a ring you have
multiple devices there you can
conception them as a range
and each device communicate with the
nearby
device the key Insight here is that can
fully overlap the
communication by using the blockwise
Transformer
I think I want to mention the asmatic
intensity here so what is athematic
intensity it stands for the ratio
between the computation and
communication so let's say if I send a
matrix two Matrix to
TPU that this two Matrix require certain
number of bytes right to
communicate and the GPU do the matrix
multiplication right we going to take
some
flops take some time okay so the amount
of flops needed divided by the number of
buys you need to communicate it matrix
it's called asmatic
intensity and this table here and we'll
get back to them later because I some
other stuff I want to talk
about this the takeway here is
that after we reorganize the computation
graph can easily
overlap all the communication
cost so using multiple gpus training and
millions of tokens per sequence
does not incur any overhead so you don't
pay an extra price for doing
that just keep
pleas this figure shows that in the in
end to endend large scale
training using blockwise Transformer and
renion you can do hundreds of times
longer sequence L than any prior State
Mars so essentially you are only Bound
by the number of
tpus and there's no
bottleneck um the contact size you can
TR almost up to any longer sequence L
you can TR on videos you can TR on
entire books and so
on
and I guess we can take a brief break
here oh yeah
question yeah it's exact attention and
it's compatible with approximations
because we essentially break down the
end to end interaction into piece by
piece like a chunk by chunk so if you
want to apply certain approximation
techniques you can apply
them
yeah
yeah yeah that's a good question
so since R attention applies to
inference case right we can split your
key value cache cross div different
devices the technique page data
attention you mentioned is for managing
key value cache in memory right better
placement in memory so I think they are
complimentary why focus on how do I
distribute really Le Qing cash across
device the one focus on page data
attention focus on how may I better
manage the memory placement on each
device so yeah so they
complimentary so I want to talk about
some multi model briefly and then next
lecture we're going to dive deeper
um since we can do mil and sequence
modeling it becomes natural to model not
only
text you know we have books we have L
paragraphs but
but the world is not just
text the world is not only human
discovered knowledges it's also about
the virtual world action and so
on so it's very natural
to model entire world both version and
text it turns out with block by
Transformer
fion we can get highly effective 1
million context
window this is a
test and the model's performance in
terms of retrieving
fact from the input context xaxis is a
input lens the ranges from 1K to 1
million y AIS is a location of randomly
placed it fact and green
represent model
accurately retrieved the
fact so the figure show that model can
indeed has a hand effective one Min
context
window and this model
outperforms GPT 4 and gam
L gam light gets like 50% accuracy
across across the context window and GPT
4 can do up to
100K and with this
techniques it now becomes possible to do
millions of SE
n in this in our next lecture we're
going to dive deeper on this here is
a some quick previews of what you can do
if you
train autor regress
models and text and
videos the model can generate videos can
generate text
images and you can understand questions
about all these modalities
this
examples probably not as impressive as
Sora
but you can easily scale up this Auto
regession models and we talked about the
previous half first half of the
lecture Alo regressive model scales very
well and now you can also model
extremely L
sequences since it's
Al model can answer your questions about
input whether it's text images or our
line
videos
well shorter context model like gp4
Gemini
couldn't
understand the recent G 1.5
model it's very
impressive they also scale this context
L to 1
million
and these two figures
shows how the LW scale across the
sequence
position
interestingly all these curves behave
like
parallel but the x-axis is no longer
compute is the sequence Dimension is
it's more like the sequence
position now we see
that
as you build longer context window the
model gets consistently lower prediction
Lo so M understand the text better and
more
interestingly the more understand the
code really well you can see this the
right
figure is the loss on the code on the
code the code is really complicated so
by conditioning on more context the
model predict code much better you can
see the trend is long stopping and at
the 10 million location it's
even outperform the scaling power of
fitted
curve so this FR ger 1.5 they show that
with one Min cont export can directly
analyze the entire code
reple
so now we are not very far away from
generating entire code
base I understand really complex
document like over 1,000
pages and the there this their model can
even output from the state of art
whisper whisper who for those who don't
know it's more like it's uh audio to
text model from
OPI and this Sho the power end end to
endend General solution you train a
single model and all the different
modalities end to end and the
model performs much better than if you
train two different state of art model
whisper and gp4 put them together it's
much worse that a general
solution and what's impressive is that
issue you can do low resources
translation so there's a language called
caman that basically there only exist
like 250k tokens that's amount of tokens
available and in this world and it's
really hard for human to
understand but but if you put this
grammar book all the available
information available put this in the
context
window turns out this AI model can
translate can understand the
grammar extremely well outperforms a
human expert who speak in this
language so that's about longer
sequence now I want to talk about some
other uh
things
um so this is called flash
attention
um flat attention is about how we reduce
data movement during training so
previously we talk about how we
reorganize attention computation
graph
but in more than
machines we have a
hierarchy we have really fast GPU s run
we have a much larger but much slower
memory called
hbn hbm is us the memory you are aware
you know like A180 gabes that's the
hbm and when you do the computation you
want to load whatever tensors you want
in to the s r to do the matrix
multiplication but Sr is small it's very
expensive you can't build a really large
Sr
so this
work
designed they basically Implement a you
know a Cuda
implementation that
explicitly tell the
compiler okay keep this um ATT tension
weight you know a chunk in S1 don't move
it out to hbn because that's immediately
needed for attention weights multiply
Rue uh Matrix so straightforward but
this needs to
um better compute better scut so this is
um
maybe a better visualization how the uh
compute works you have query chunk and
the key vanue
chunk and the red one shows that which
part should be stored in srun and the
principle is whatever you need
immediately next you store that into Sr
you don't want to move that back and
forth because that's takes
time okay that's the
principle and this is called flash
attention it outperform from the vanina
pyou buildin uh attention
computation and
uh in Flash attention one they somehow
choose to do key value as a out Loop
query as inner loop but as we previously
mentioned the curry is independent from
each other so cury should be outer loop
right you can minimize the communication
so that's also simpler so in flashion to
they switch it this bike
uh that again brings another uh pretty
significant uh
boost so um tool I
use and the
retrieval you know um it's not
sufficient to just train a language
model
and and then we hope that that this
language model can do
everything because we don't have the
language model does not have access to
up to-date
information it's trained on the data set
you previously
curate and then know some fractural know
because you it's really difficult to
minimize your loss to you know zero
right U so model does not compress all
the faction
images and as we want to build a really
capable a models we hope this models are
as smart as humans
in utilizing external tools
so there's a wide research area on this
but I'm going to only give an example on
retrieval but you can check out uh some
reference later on um about um other
exciting
research so this a paper called retro uh
that aims to retrieve information from a
given data set okay the idea
is
maybe some information that are not
encoded in the language model yet can be
retrieved somehow to improve the
language model
prediction the idea is the train a birth
edding you know a really tiny small
model
and then they do K years labor
retrieval what do I mean by that you
have a input token sequence you run that
through the birth
embedding you also run the data set bir
eding have so many edings and you do
kers labor retrieval find the labors and
put this labors back uh into this cross
attention uh in uh this neuron networks
so it's not just self attention it's
also attending to retrieve the
neighbors okay uh that's the
idea this is a retrieval
part you can pre you can basically cach
the embeddings for the data set to save
compute and then run a frozen K and
retriever and they designed some um ways
to um accelerate this
computation
um we can skip that
um so this show that by incorporating
such retrieval from external data sets
um for certain tasks that about you know
mostly focus on like fractural stuff and
so on um they get a better scaling so
for the same amount of
parameters you remember there are some
extra birth parameters but birth is
small model there so
um you get a consistently better
performance that shows the benefit of
doing
retrieval and across different tasks
this the big scan can seems come from
the GitHub and P9 P9 is the book data
set okay so uh this seems to indicate
that uh retrieval is most helpful when
you can't attend to the full context
right so get help is pretty long and
books is pretty long so if you can't
train non context model then one way is
to do retrieval you know to retrial
whatever uh needed information to help
prediction
okay um so some alternatives to the uh
self attention uh architecture so um
something is called sliding window
attention um so in the v attention where
each token attend to all the previous
tokens and you know that means a lot of
computation cost right in quadratic
computation cost and Al we have
techniques to reduce the memory cost you
know we can TR millions of context LS uh
but computer cost is still there so one
way to reduce computer cost is do the
sliding window attention um the idea is
that um as we uh attemp to a fix the
window and as we go deeper in the layers
um each token effectively attend to
distant uh past okay so this is a like a
a trade off uh between R attention and
uh you know maybe uh recurr to NE
networks so because this is still fast
to train and
uh and it seems to work well in practice
not as good as vanina attention but you
know yeah it's good to know about
this um and and another I would say
pretty promising alternative to
attention is called a state space model
um it's pretty promising idea though uh
it's a little bit unclear how it would
scale compared with Transformer uh but
yeah it's good to know about this the
idea is uh I won't go into the full
detail but the idea is um it's kind of
like um recurrent neuron Network
architecture um the model maintains some
hidden State about distant past uh but
rather than doing this uh in the you
know sstm you know can of uh exact
sequential way they can somehow
accelerate this a little bit but you by
paralyzing uh some of the
computation so it's pretty promising
because it shows faster inference uh and
uh which which is ideal for many of the
applications uh and they it's also
better than so yeah it yeah but yeah gu
more research needed
um so this is a uh a recent model called
mber um
one of the uh models in state space
model family um this is a uh SC L
studies from a paper um we can say that
um M performs out performs all the past
of the previous state space model uh in
terms of scaling because all the past
model they see they were not able to uh
match Transformers scaling um the M
seems to uh match Transformers uh and
this this is a very small scale this is
like a one bilon model three bilon model
it's pretty small scale but it seems to
match uh Transformers uh pretty well
although as as you can see as you scale
up the compute the curve seems to go a
little bit higher than Transformers so
um but I would say this is a pretty
promising idea
yeah so people also explor how can we
maybe combine
with State space model because a state
space model seem to underperform by
Transformers so maybe you can someh out
combine them together uh so one way to
do that is called uh how about combining
sliding window attention right so it's a
relatively cheap form of attention uh to
model the long range dependency right
because in recurrent neur Network you
know State space model the count model
long range dependency as well uh because
you have to store information into a
fixed data hidden State um so people
explored how to combine them um and this
is from a recent paper Cod based
um they the the basically show that uh
by combining these two on this simple
retrieval task you can somehow uh you
can get pretty close to uh one your
networks and how to perform um stat
Space Mod only models like mamba or
other model they are you know they
perform worse than this new architecture
so um this is a concurrent work from def
mind um you need the same idea
um combining this kind of attention with
some recurrent neuron networks um it's
good to know about them
uh this is a um a down string evaluation
across some tasks people care about uh
so we can see that if we look at the
average performance this
model is blue highlighted models uh
perform quite competitive with uh um
Vana Transformer uh and also you can see
using half of the data they out perform
State space model only models that's us
twice much tokens so uh this shows that
attention is uh seems uh pretty crucial
for uh High performing models uh but uh
State space model could also be combined
together to improve U maybe uh inference
deficiency as shown here um uh these
Hybrid models has a a pretty uh cool uh
inference efficiency compare with uh the
mq stands for the vanina Transformer and
the other two are newly proposed Hybrid
models so they have this scale better in
at the inference they have better um
support so I I previous mentioned the Q
value cach multiple times U so let's do
a recap on that um
so at the inference time giving a input
sequence prompt
um for the following questions you know
like a as the model answer the question
you generate the auto regress output
each word you know the query only need
to attend to the cach data input right
we don't need to recompute everything
right we can have cach the input and
only need to do the query and the cach
Del ke manual
computation it may explain that where
well
um the um a
pink pink dat parts are basically the
cached key value um so with for new quer
rates uh we can um save a lot of
computation
by only doing this query attending to
cach that key
value yeah doesn't it assume it's
linear or where's the soft
softmax over key value softmax over key
query key query don't you to do a soft
Max after the key query multiplication
yes you need to do that yeah so you have
the four key value available keys and
values are separately cached yeah they
are cached yeah yeah so the the save dat
the computation comes from not
recomputing the qy value yeah so the
computation cost become
linear but linear with respected to cach
the Q value size so with as the Q value
size gets bigger the linear cost also
goes
up so this may explain that
um we
gradually um cach the uh Q value for
previous
tokens and such that for new
token we don't need to recompute the
Past key
value and yeah saving the computer is
nice
but the bottom neck is loading the key
value
um so this figure shows that
um ever since an net came out you know
2012 we are keep building better and
better gpus
um they have exponentially increasing
flops on each
gpus but the memory
badway scales very
slowly so the time needed to load the
key value
cach increases as we have longer and
longer
input so same computes great but the
time is dominated
by loading key value
cache and it also incurs a pretty
significant memory
cost so this fig show that if we go from
sance 500 to
100K most of the memory cost comes from
saving the key value
cache so people propose techniques to
compress key manual cache
um which I want to get into um it's
there are many cool techniques in this
direction I encourage you to check them
out um I want to highlight this one
particular is that it show by uh
compressing the KE value cache
um they we can still get nearly the
same
quality so as we so basically sh that
there are a lot of redundancies in ke
value cach so we can basically compress
them without significantly damaging the
model
performance the more uh very popular
technique is called multi querer
attention
um in the multi querer attention we have
only one key value for different
queries okay so basically you have we
have um 32 number of attention heads
right
typically so rather than having
32 key value per token and 32
queries query head per
token let's reduce the number of key
value to one okay this is called a
multiquery because you have one Q value
and you have multiple query so that
that's why they call is multiquery
um the benefits is that you don't need
to load
32 different key value per token you
only need to load you you have 32 number
of head times fewer key value to
load but that that actually turns out to
hurt model performance quite
significantly because we know M head is
quite crucial for model performance so
uh there's called technique called group
carer attention uh it's more like a
tradeoff um you instead of 32 instead of
one it's maybe have a four um key value
and then we group The quates into four
groups So within each group The quer is
attend to um you know that particular uh
key
value this this turns out to give a very
nice tradeoff between inference Speed
and Performance so we can see that the
the gqa model has uh the best the the
fast speed to sample and also has the
high you know the second best
performance uh among these different
variants and in practice you can convert
your multi head attention to gqa or to
uh mqa um by just you know you can maybe
merge some of the head together by
taking the average for instance and then
train continue train the model on
additional small percentage of data so
this figure show that you only need
maybe 10% of your pre-training data to
successfully convert uh the pre-trained
multier attention to group query
attention so something uh on the
hardware side to be aware of
is
potentially we can have much bigger band
Ways by stacking the memory on top of GP
die why is
that I think as AI researchers we need
to know where this bottom coming from
so in
existing
chips we place the m
next to the GPU
die
so the flops
scales with the GPU die right the bigger
the area the more
flops but your bway can only scale with
the parameter of your GPU die right
because you put your memory next to the
GPU die so you can only talk to the GPU
using the parameter so that explain the
gap between flops and band ways so there
are so
many many cool research techniques on
you know reducing the memory banway cost
you know designing new architectures
like a state space model and so
on but as we put the memory on top of GP
die both flops and bandwith can scale
with the
area
that could close the gap between flops
and
bands once that's true I think there are
a lot of companies in media and AMD are
heav investigating this once this is
true we can also run Matrix Vector
multiplication very very efficiently we
can run large context inference very
efficiently so there are a lot of
research
opportunities now some ideas That
Couldn't that were considered
impractical could have potentially
become really impactful in the
future so
um mixture of experts it's uh you
probably heard about that due to
G4 uh you know
like right people talk about gp4 is a
mixture of experts so why we need
mixture of expert and what is murex
expert experts here stand for the number
of MLP networks in each Transformer
layer and originally we have one MLP
followed it by following
attention and actually you can have
multiple
MLPs you know and then you have some you
train some neuron Network to
select which one or which two multiple
from this group you know from this many
potentially you know 32 or even more
MLPs to to the forward so this works um
per token okay it's good to know
that we do this per token we select you
know maybe one of the MLP to do the
computation so what's the motivation
right why we do something like that why
not we train a giant
MLP the motivation is we want to decle
computation from the
parameters normally the comput is
bounded to the parameters right remember
the computer cost say equals roughly
like six time your parameters and data
size so if you want to increase your
number of parameters you want to tr big
newws you have to pay more computer
cost typically you want to Decap these
things now decaling means more
flexibilities and the mixture of
expert in my opinion is a way to
decample
compute and
parameters so the re m model shows this
very nicely this show
that you can have eight MLPs per
layer and they decide to activate two
out of the eight per
token okay so they didn't increase the
compute cost or the you know
dramatically it's still reasonable
compute but there are lot of more
parameters almost eight times parameters
because most of the parameter are in MLP
so now they have eight times more par ml
they have eight times more
parameters in return Yeah question
uh you finish your thought oh yeah no
yeah what's the
question like basically you said you
select N Out of the all all out of all
the experts you select n
yeah let's say you have 32 experts maybe
you want to say next one or two and what
what matters is the ratio okay you could
have 256 expert and select eight and
then the ratio is I don't know maybe 36
32 or something yeah um anyway the ratio
is what matters uh and uh yeah what
what's the question again well so I was
wondering seems like how is that
selection procedure continuous or I mean
differentiable because I feel like if
you just selected
one like how do you learn this sort of
selection proc right because like if
it's a continuous if it's a like
discontinous like I'm going to take this
one or this one how do you learn with gr
and descent which one as like is it like
continuous
approximation yeah so good question you
can think of this as a classification
par right you have eight experts and you
want to select one so you can do output
eight logics let's say which one is the
largest and then select that
one okay and that's that's the one
you're going to send your yeah that's
one you're going to use for the forward
forward and backward for this
token so you're going to predict which
expert to use for every
token
yeah yeah so learning this selection
module
is I would say it's the bottom make you
know right because predicting which
expert to use is a difficult problem
intuitively right
um yeah it it is I know
why yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a good
intuition so but uh yeah but using
multiple experts the the
Branded benefits is quite significant
even if learning the um the routing
module is difficult yeah so this Bally
show that uh by increasing Xpress to
eight you get uh a model that out
performs even bigger models right
um even out performs n 70 billion
parameters so it's pretty
impressive although the data sets are
different
um okay so um
and another way to look at this
is the number of active parameters okay
question yeah yeah this is sort of the
add on to the previous question let's
say you only have one expert how do
you uh when you're when you're doing
gradient descent it seems like you
wouldn't have information like if
there's eight experts and you're only
choosing to run one of them it's you
don't really have a method of
determining which of the other sevenes
would have been better to run in that
situation so like I guess you don't
really have the gradients needed to say
that you should increase the classifier
probility of choosing any of those other
is there can you clarify exactly how it
knows to choose one of those other that
choose yeah people tune up temperature
to as a hyper parameter that encourage
the model to maybe explore other EXP
rather than blandly choose uh according
to the
Logics yeah and I think there are even
other techniques like maybe adding a
entropy uh regularization to encourage
uh exploration to other experts yeah
yeah that's indeed a problem that you
know if you have eight experts and you
only select one then there's a
probability that the model maybe tend to
choose only y z and then the other s
experts are not sufficiently trained in
know end yeah that's a good question
yeah isn't the alternative to during
training just do a soft combination of
the
experts yeah that's a good point if you
do soft confirmation then we are not
decarbing compute from parameters during
training to get better
priation oh you turn down the
temperature and it becomes more and more
selective over time in time you can
yeah yeah that's doable uh I think
people tried that and uh I I would
say that's a good idea you know you only
pay the extra computer cost at the
training time but not a test time but
there's a gap right if you use all the
experts during training and then at the
inference time you only use maybe two
experts
then how could the model know um
yeah I mean you want to turn down the
temperature gradually
dur even during training can barely use
the others the the other goes down to
roughly zero oh I see to just like the
soft Max on on the values it would be
like a soft Max on the experts
effectively oh I see what you mean
gradually decrease the temperature so
model gradually learns to use only one
or two experts yeah that's a great idea
I I think it's a it makes sense yeah you
don't think it's done uh to the best of
my which I am not aware that
for would this be equivalent in some
way enforce the only have one Matrix
butfor it
was block uhhuh and then you kind of
create experts again I mean like are
they is the dimension of each expert
like kind of merged it just go into the
same Dimension or does each expert like
go to
separate part of your
output
so once you select this out let say one
xert one MLP the output from this expert
is FedEd into the nest layer okay but
each expert Bas the same dimensions
right same Dimension yeah I think
technically you can do it's not Zer
everywhere else it's really help mhm
yeah yeah if you do zero and then use a
giant Matrix then you are still paying
the flows
right cool uh so this show that using
the same number of active parameters in
the M mixture
expert out performs L mixture of expert
model so this shows the benefit of doing
you know uh de component compute and the
parameters
something interesting that although you
know
um several years ago when Hinton and his
course proposed this mixture of expert
idea they were thinking about you know
like maybe one expert correspond to one
particular topic or domain but turns
out in language model you if you look at
Arab GitHub or papers and you know these
different domains or c
and you look at how each
layer select which expert to use there
seems no correlation between certain
aspect and certain
topics so um this again confirms the
hypothesis that the benefit is comes
from De comping parameters and the
compute not from like you know I I maybe
it's better to learn one expert for ARA
one expert for GitHub and so on it
doesn't seem to be so although that' be
nice uh that seems more interpretable
um all right um let's talk about some
language model capabilities um some
reasoning
capabilities
so few years ago and probably still true
today
is Alo we have really capable models
that can generate Cod
cancer questions or you know like a
where to have lunch and dinner and so
on they are
mysteriously bad at
reasoning and particularly on asthmatic
reasoning
this is the bottom NE because if the
model can't do simple reasoning really
well how can we trust a models to
discover new
technique or to become AI doctors or AI
lawyers and so on
so how may we address this
problem the dominating approach so far
is fan tuning on a lot of data okay you
have human right something like this you
know you hire a bunch of human
labelers write down the step by step
thinking of these asthmatic problems and
you hope these models can learn to do
this step by step thinking at inference
time to give you a better
answer this indeed works very well
as you increase the training set
size the test accuracy continue to go up
although it's still pretty low that
because this is this is a paper from a
few years ago nowadays you can get like
80% accuracy uh pretty
easily and the reason is we get way
better pre-training model we spend way
more efforts on connecting this funing
data
so F requires a lot of data here for
this reason for improving model's
reasoning one way to improve
this is called scratch
Pad scratch Pad works by
having really detailed step by step
thinking as training data you know for
this particular example
here rather than having the final answer
directly as in this example right I have
this example
directly you write
down the thinking process you even write
down the language explanation you know
as a
comment and then you find the model to
predict
this this works for
everywhere
the
interation because model have fixed the
number of
layers so M can only do number of layers
steps thinking if you only allow the
model to do one forward pass
right and that's not enough for most of
the problems we care about you know we
have 32 layers that's not enough 32
steps not enough for most
problems but if you allow the model to
do step by step in know multi-step
thinking along the context Dimension you
know we have really big context right if
you allow the model you teach the model
to do step by step thinking and
theoretically you almost getting a true
machine that can use the tape you know
infinitely large
tape
that's an
interation and this is a a really cool
technique for improving
reasoning but it seems that there's
there are some other bottom legs you
know as you can see the the a of
distribution accuracy you know the
rightmost figure uh is still pretty no
um showing that the
model doesn't seem to really understand
understand how to do the reasoning
um so yeah more research needed
here so the scratch Pad requires fine
tuning people found that okay I don't
want to do fan tuning can I just tell
the model the step by step thinking give
it a few to give the model some examples
you know few short prompting then
hopefully the model learns to do that
and this called CH s
prompting they put multiple examples of
scratch Pad as
input and the model
imitates the F short
prompt this indate lead to Performance
that's even close to supervisor F un so
pretty cool
that model seems to understand the
reasoning from future examples and can
perform competitively with ftuned
model later on researchers found
that maybe maybe you don't need the few
short
examples maybe just ask the model to to
Sy step by step uh this called this zero
short t
s there a mod directly output the
thinking
process I'm guessing that this is
because later on you know with instruct
GPT and other more capable models they
were already trained on some of this
kind of Step by Step thinking data so
you we don't we no longer need to write
the prompts anymore uh because you know
over on the internet there are many such
data
um so it's really cool to see that you
can prompt the model with just one
sentence to you uh let the model
generate this reasoning and then you do
the reasoning uh to get that final
answer yeah it performs pretty well uh
and uh
performs performs the best on the
largest model available I I I guess with
larger models
they capture such stepbystep thinking
data in the data set better than small
model because they have more capability
to to me memorize uh these uh particular
examples on the
internet
this is indeed true for all the models
available today because they are heav
many instruction funed
using uh this kind of Step by Step
thinking
so so we can do this uh Champa prompting
without manual examples
anymore so one way people find that
to improve the reasoning further more is
by using something called a process
feedback so rather than giving the final
step answer you know like whether the
final answer is correct or not we want
to tell the model which step is
incorrect this gives much better
performance
than
the outcome
supervision process supervision by
humans or automatic by human yeah I
should note that this is labeled it by
human um so it's uh it's very expensive
um but I would say in the future maybe
we can rely on AI models to provide this
process feedback and one ni says that
compare with outcome
supervision process supervision doesn't
seem to saturate
yet
um yeah but I should note that this is
really expensive to to collect you need
you need well trained human laborers and
it's pretty
difficult so want to also note the I HF
stands for reinforcement learning for
from Human
feedback many of you already are
probably already familiar with this
because CH GPT took off uh generated a
lot of news
um a quick recap is the consist of St
steps connecting human
demonstration to the supervis f
Contin and then collect this outcome
separation you know like model generate
two response it label
one as
preferred this is not process superation
this is outcome superation because this
is more
scalable and then your TR reward
model and then you run PP reinforcement
earning against this reward function to
maximize
reward since the reward captures human
preference ideally by writing by running
po you the final
model aligns better with human
preference that's that's indeed true
showing in
experiments the P model performs
significantly better than
just supervise F the
mode another capability I want to note
is code Generation
Um the code generation has a lot of
potentials and
likely the SK also holds for code data
not only for language data so this is a
code X the backbone of GitHub Co pilot
um you see
that it has different scaling no
constant as we previous mentioned SC no
constant uh data set
dependent but fortunately uncode going
also
HED and the accuracy also h
with bigger model it get much
higher accuracy so the pass one and the
pass 100 are both
like the code correctness rate if you
generate one solution per problem or if
you generate 100 Solutions per
problem so the pass one is probably the
most important and you you see that it
increases with larger
model and over context Dimension code no
scales very nice as well um the scills
much better than text as we would expect
because text human text are written
by you know like a general public and we
don't write extremely difficult
extremely difficult understand text but
for code you know you have to keep track
of modules functions to have like you
know to get code to work so code is more
complicated is longer
so larger context window allows much
better um code
understanding alha code proposed that
and interesting technique I say called
inference
optimization so rather than doing the
pre-training and funing
only they also did large scale sampling
at test time so they they have some
filtering methods to filter
out
solutions from a very large uh sample
dat data set you know s
Solutions and this matters
for competition level
problems again this is different from
previous par previous um graphs because
this measures the competition level
problems it's way harder so you can see
that without filtering it's nearly zero
uh
solate but with filtering you know this
inference t
optimization you can solve 30% of the
competition level coding
problems and I guess you can probably do
this either run you have the model
generate large scale sampl name and the
filtering and then you do supervise fan
tuning
again what is 10
10 yeah
so is it means like if I sample um Cas
Solutions and then I
measure how many of them are
correct you want it to be at least 10
mhm so turns out if you want to improve
code
generation the biggest gain seems to
come from better pre-training so this
show that if you
replace the back bone model with G Pro
which is a um a improved
version compared with pal pal was the
model used in alha code if I remember
correctly so turns out you have a if you
have a much better pre-training model
and you easily get
uh way better performance in code
generation so inference time technique
is pretty cool and better pre- trending
model can get you a long way
ahead so for those who are curious
typically when the pre-training data set
comes from the internet okay the pile -
CC stands for common
CW CC stands for common C common C is
basically a a data set curated from the
internet okay all the different websites
and so
on it's good to know about this you know
where the data come from uh the majority
of the data comes from the internet so
we need a heavy filtering as you could
imagine right um or many of the data are
I I wouldn't say they good ideal data so
you need a heavy
filter um so lambas data set is
calibrated towards Wikipedia it's a
really good humanistic you train a
classifier using Wikipedia data and data
set that you know are not a Wikipedia
you train a logistic regression okay uh
to classify this and then you can run
this classifier over other you know on a
large chunk of you know very large data
set to filter out data that are not uh
similar to Wikipedia this turns out to
be a good humanistic and by doing the
data correctly Lama of also with you
know good optimization technique and so
on um Nama outperforms
gpdr um in the palm and other models
so when you do your res research or work
um pay attention to the data
set so there are some open source data
set Lama data set was not made publicly
available due to you know legal issues
and so on
um R pajama is a pretty good uh
alternative um um me and my corer try to
um reproduce Nama using the red Pama
data set and some um further filtering
done by ourselves uh we can match n
performance pretty
easily so
um I guess uh the rest of the lecture is
mostly about um practical side of the uh
language model training I guess we we
can cover this in future lectures and we
are right about that so
yeah thank you
h